to present the Oscar for Best Director
the Academy has chosen an actress who
needs absolutely no direction she has
such style such grace uh charm and when
she glides on the set the cameras start
turning by themselves ms leslie her own
yeah Bob who is your favorite director I
figured direct a Liz Taylor oh well she
doesn't know the best thing about
directing like you make your pictures
I'll make mine the distinguished
gentlemen who have been nominated for
best achievement in directing are Arthur
Penn for Bonnie and Clyde Mike Nichols
for the Graduate Stanley Kramer for
guess who's coming to dinner Richard
Brooks for in cold blood and Norman
Jewison for in the heat of the night and
now the winner the winner is Mike
Nichols
until this moment my greatest pleasure
in the Graduate was making it because
it's a picture made by a group and we
cared for each other and we cared for
what we were doing so this award quite
literally belongs to them at least as
much as it does to me I'm grateful to
them and to the Academy and to the
movies themselves and I'd also like to
wish my mother a happy birthday